I was actually really against making
content for a long time and it was
because I actually saw the content as
temporary why would I make a short video
that's going to disappear in the news
feed and never get seen again like it
just felt like a complete waste of time
but what I realized was that the media
is not the compounding asset the
audience is the compounding asset it
sounds so simple whatever painfully
obvious I didn't get it so that was why
for years I never made it because I was
like why would I make content because
it's going to disappear but the audience
doesn't and there are the people who
tell two people or four people Etc and
then that becomes the base I'm sharing
this right now because like it took me
too long to figure it out